on commence avec l'iPhone 12 qui est
désormais interdit à la vente en France
il a accusé de mettre des des
ondes trop puissantes qu'elles sont
concrètement les risques pour la santé
de ceux qui les possède l'Agence
nationale des fréquences qui est
l'autorité de surveillance des
équipements radio et donc des téléphones
lors de ses contrôles routiniers à
contrôler si on peut dire l'iPhone 12 à
un niveau légèrement supérieur à la
norme européenne cette norme elle est
elle-même dix fois inférieure au seuil à
partir duquel les l'exposition en tout
cas les études scientifiques estiment
que l'exposition peut avoir des
conséquences pour la santé
il peut être corrigé avec une simple
mise à jour logicielle donc la NFR a
décidé d'interdire la commercialisation
ma responsabilité c'est de veiller à ce
que cette interdiction soit respectée
parce que la règle est la même pour tous
et y compris pour les géants Apple à 15
jours pour se mettre en conformité
qu'est-ce qui se passe si elle refuse
une nouvelle fois ce qui suffit de faire
sur l'iPhone 12 c'est une simple mise à
jour logicielle Apple à 15 jours pour
répondre à la mise en demeure de
l'Agence nationale des fréquences et lui
dire comment elle va mettre en place
cette mise à jour logicielle si Apple
refusait de faire cette mise à jour
alors je me réserve la possibilité de
faire usage de mes pouvoirs de police
des fréquences et leur donner leur
rappel de ces téléphones mais j'ai toute
confiance en l'essence de responsabilité
de cette grande entreprise du numérique
pour qu'elle fasse dans les temps la
mise à jour nécessaire donc très
concrètement si moi je suis propriétaire
d'un iPhone 12 je garde mon iphone 12 et
j'attends les mises à jour possibles
vous le gardez vous attendez la mise à
jour et c'est important peut-être même
si c'est pas tout à fait le sujet du
jour de le rappeler il est important de
de garder nos téléphones portables parce
que si nous voulons contenir voire même
réduire l'empreinte carbone du secteur
du numérique et bien l'essentiel de
cette carbone ce sont nos téléphones
donc si nous les gardons un petit peu
plus longtemps nous contribuons à la
réduction de l'empreinte carbone
dernière question est-ce que vous allez
rappeler tous les modèles qui sont mis
sur le marché bien sûr que non les
contrôles que la NFR ont fait ne
concerne en tout cas pour le dépassement
que l'iPhone 12 l'iPhone 12 Pro l'iPhone
12 Pro max ne sont pas concernés et les
autres modèles d'iPhone ne sont pas
concernés non plus mais vous demandez
pas aux propriétaires d'iPhone 12 de
revenir pour rendre leur téléphone et
pas du tout il s'agit d'une mesure
conservatoire si l'on peut dire le temps
que la mise à jour soit faite si la mise
à jour n'était pas faite alors la
question du rappel ne se poserait elle
ne se pose pas aujourd'hui
un mot après d'aborder vos sujets
d'actualité le groupe Sephora France a
publié lundi sur Instagram une vidéo de
rencontre avec l'équipe des hits jabus
alors les diabus c'est un collectif qui
a pour objectif de défendre le port du
voile lors de les compétitions de
football on les voit dans cette vidéo
dans leur routine beauté quotidienne
jusque
terrain de foot est-ce que ces vidéos
alors elle est postée sur Instagram par
l'entreprise est-ce que cette vidéo vous
choque rappelons que le 29 juin le
Conseil d'État a clairement dit que la
Fédération Française de foot était
fondée à interdire le port du voile sur
les terrains de foot
qu'une entreprise comme Sephora Vienne
utiliser ce litige qui a eu lieu avant
l'été pour faire de la pub je trouve que
ça relève de la faute de goût de la
faute de goût mais vous n'avez pas la
main là-dessus il y a pas d'idées
égalité excusez-moi dans cette dans
cette vidéo
je trouve ça assez étrange de venir
faire de la pub si l'on peut dire sur le
dos d'une décision du Conseil d'État
donc vous réunissez demain un groupe
transpartisan donc c'est vraiment des
députés de tous les partis vous
réunissez aussi des experts avec une
question comment gérer en temps de crise
les réseaux sociaux concrètement par
exemple pendant les émeutes qu'est-ce
que vous auriez pu faire qu'est-ce que
vous auriez voulu faire est-ce que vous
auriez voulu par exemple interdire les
échanges
dès le début des émeutes le président de
la République nous a demandé à Gérald
Darmanin et à moi-même de convoquer les
réseaux sociaux pour leur demander de
respecter leurs obligations légales
retrait des contenus il sites réponse
aux réquisitions de la justice pour
pouvoir mener les enquêtes nous leur
avons demandé aussi d'aller un peu plus
loin et de veiller à ce que les
fonctionnalités les algorithmes de leur
plateforme ne viennent pas être dévoyés
au service des émeutes et dans la foulée
nous avons rassemblé réunis un groupe
transpartisan qui compte une quinzaine
de groupes politiques pour pouvoir
aborder sereinement l'analyse de la
situation et les mesures à en tirer les
conséquences à en tirer nous avons réuni
j'ai réuni ce groupe deux fois une
troisième une troisième réunion jeudi
on peut aussi dire attendez c'est la
liberté d'expression si vous commencez à
verrouiller cadenacées les réseaux
sociaux quand ça arrange le gouvernement
s'il y a des grosses manifestations s'il
y a des gilets jaunes absolument
une information qu'il faut veiller à
préserver et je rappelle que les réseaux
sociaux dans bien des pays du monde qui
n'ont pas la chance d'avoir nos
institutions démocratiques sont des
outils de résistance et de liberté donc
il faut veiller à préserver ces libertés
et par ailleurs la France a obtenu grâce
à mobilisation du président de la
République l'année dernière l'adoption
d'un règlement européen très important
qui est entré en vigueur le 25 août
dernier et qui oblige désormais les
plateformes de réseaux sociaux à veiller
à ce que leur service ne porte pas
atteinte à la sécurité publique et donc
l'enjeu des discussions que nous allons
poursuivre jeudi c'est de savoir si ce
nouveau règlement qui est tout neuf qui
vient d'entrer en vigueur et bien couvre
bien les situations comme celles des
émeutes nous avons d'ailleurs à la
demande des membres de ce groupe de
travail écrit à la Commission européenne
pour savoir si le règlement si d'autres
événements comme ce que nous avons connu
au début de l'été ce produisait si les
règles prévues dans ce règlement
s'appliquerait bien et si les
plateformes en conséquence serait bien
conduites à veiller à modérer
les fonctionnalités la viralisation des
contenus au travers de leur place
alors on se poserait la question que
nous prenions des mesures
complémentaires mais dans le respect
vous l'avez dit des libertés
fondamentales donc rendez-vous jeudi
pour la suite des discussions il y a un
autre rendez-vous c'est les JO à Paris
ça va être beaucoup de sport mais ça va
aussi être 40 milliards de spams c'est
10 fois plus qu'au JO de Tokyo alors là
aussi vous souhaitez mettre en place un
filtre anti-arnaque afin de protéger les
Français des arnaques en ligne comment
ça va marcher précisément c'était un
engagement de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
et ça sera un rempart contre les
campagnes de SMS frauduleux et vous avez
raison
on a tous hésité à cliquer on a parfois
cliqué et ce sont 18 millions de
Français qui ont été victimes de cyber
arnaque l'année dernière donc je
concrète qu'est-ce qui se passe
concrètement lorsque l'on cliquera sur
le lien de ce faux SMS et bien on sera
orienté vers une page qui nous avertira
et une page sécurisée qui nous avertira
que nous sommes en train de nous diriger
vers quoi en réalité et bien vers un
site de phishing de hansonage dont le
seul objectif et de piller nos données
personnelles et bancaires pour faire
quoi et bien pour servir à de
l'usurpation d'identité ou pour servir à
des cyber-attaques donc vous serez le
français les Français seront prévues en
amont vous deviez être prêt pour se
filtre anti-arnaque pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby c'est pas le cas est-ce
que vous pouvez nous assurer que vous
serez prêt pour les JO de Paris écoutez
on a bien avancé puisque le projet de
loi que je porte de sécurisation de
l'espace numérique qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité au Sénat avant l'été va être
examinée la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée et nous donne la capacité
juridique de le faire ensuite il y a un
chantier technique qui lui aussi avance
et qui doit être prêt pour les Jeux
Olympiques parce que vous avez raison ce
sera un moment d'intensité dans les
attaques vous parlez à l'instant de ce
projet de loi numérique vous présenter à
l'automne est-ce que vous voulez non
vous voulez lutter contre le
cyber-harcèlement en donnant plus de
pouvoir au juge de bannir des réseaux
sociaux
ceux qui ont enfin les condamner alors
pendant six mois et puis pendant un an
pour ceux qui récidivent ça va être
effectif ça va être effectivement quand
c'est une très bonne question
il y a eu un décondations lourdes à
l'encontre de personnes s'étant rendu
coupable de cyber-harcèlement je pense à
la faire Mila je pense à la faire Eddy
De Pretto ou plus récemment à la faire
Hoshi ce que nous proposons avec ce
texte c'est une peine complémentaire de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux pour
les personnes condamnées par le juge
mais je dois dire que les sénateurs qui
ont adopté ce texte à l'unanimité nous
ont poussé à aller un peu plus loin et
notamment à faire entrer dans le texte
une disposition sur lequel nous
travaillons puisque aujourd'hui elle
n'est pas tout à fait mûre qui
permettrait avant même de passer par le
juge dans certains cas et bien d'infiger
des amendes donc pour que ça aille plus
vite et nous allons travailler avec les
députés pour faire en sorte que cette
proposition et bien elle puisse être
effective plus rapidement elle serait de
quel niveau c'est des amendes
forfaitaire délictuels donc selon la
gravité de l'acte commis elles vont être
plus ou moins importantes mais ce qui
est important c'est qu'elles peuvent
être délivrées rapidement sur l'exemple
sur le modèle de l'outrage sexiste et
des amendes qui ont été créés il y a
quelques années pour sanctionner les
comportements dans l'espace physique
merci pour ces précisions Jean-Noël
barre aux